Hi everyone, in this lesson,
we're gonna talk about subsurface materials
and parallax control and how to edit
and use these inside the material editor.
So let's get started.
So inside the material editor,
we can actually control a few nodes
to be able to make materials look and function
differently than they actually are doing.
And what I mean by that is we can actually make
a translucent feel and look for an object such as ice
or even jade by simply using the Fernal Index
and plugging it in to the appropriate areas
and controlling those values.
But the object will not be translucent.
So we're basically using that Fernal Index
we described in previous classes
in which we're actually almost like bending the light
and making it look like that subsurface effect
is actually happening.
So we can use it to our advantage.
Now we'll have to control that
within the material initially
to turn on the subsurface options.
But when we do have that on,
the Fernal Index can push those values
and those looks even farther
to get a unique looking type of ice or even jade,
which we're going to look at in just a bit.
Feel free to follow along in the slides
as we go through an Unreal
and you'll be able to build these materials
the way that they're described and shown in this lesson.
So let's go and jump into Unreal.
So I'm in Unreal right now
and I'm using the map that's called MatSub.
You'll find that underneath our class folder
and you'll see a folder called maps
and you'll see MatSub right there.
Inside here, you can see that we have a jade material,
an ice material and a more complicated jade
using a parallax control,
or I should say a parallax effect,
which you see down below here.
And this is using that parallax occlusion shader.
And we're mainly going to focus on this one first,
and then we'll come over and take a look at ice
and its complexity.
From there, we'll look at the parallax control
and how to use that parallax occlusion shader
and compare it to a bump offset,
which we talked about in other classes.
And then finally, from there,
we'll take a look at our subsurface profile
and how that stacks up,
as well as the Megascans blend
and the regular subsurface we're dealing with now.
Let's go ahead and take a look over here in our scene
and see the light of being affected,
or I should say, affecting the object,
object's material in the scene.
So I've moved this light down and it is behind the object.
You'll see that it appears to be having light
pass through it as if we're controlling how thin it is.
Now this is kind of an optical illusion,
you can think, in Unreal.
And we're using our subsurface profile,
which already has a few things built in in the material.
I shouldn't say profile,
but the options to turn on that mode in our material.
And with that, we're also plugging in our Fernal Index.
And that Fernal Index pushes that subsurface look
and feel a bit farther.
Let me show you what I mean.
So I'm going to click on this particular object
and I'm going to double click on its parent material.
We'll see its parent material here,
or I should say, instance material.
We'll see the instance material here broken down,
where I've sectioned off different types and pieces
that we can actually add to compliment this object.
You'll notice we have a color for masking,
a color for noise and a color for noise too.
Now this is just to be able to get this thing
to look a little bit more robust
and to be able to control some of the values.
And what I mean by that, if I go in here,
I can add color that can compliment
and make this look very unique.
You can even make this look like it's from another planet
or even a material that doesn't necessarily exist on earth.
And you can control that simply
by playing with those colors.
So I wanted to give those opportunities in there.
I'll show you in the parent material,
what those look like.
Then we also have these simple material conditions here.
We have metallic, roughness and spec,
and down below we have normal and normal intensity.
But over here we have opacity edits.
We're controlling the fall off of the frontal index effect
from the center on this object,
plugged into the appropriate areas in the opacity.
We also see here opacity subsurface amount.
So we actually can control a bit of that in our scene.
Again, I will show you and break that down some more.
You'll see here we have subsurface control,
edge control, spec reflection,
and subsurface color overall.
All right, so the arrestor is your standard of values
that you can see in here,
such as our light settings and material property overrides.
Down below you'll see there's a little bit
of texture noise that I added
if we wanted to add some more noise.
It works okay in here, it's not too bad,
but unfortunately what we have here
is these textures don't have the same UVs in mind.
It's just stuff I plugged in here.
So you may see seams show up
based on where the shells begin and end,
because these are just simple texture,
texture slapped into the scene.
So just keep that in mind.
They may not do anything,
but I wanted to show you this in theory,
what you can do to maybe enhance the look and feel
for an object,
simply by getting some texture information in there.
All right, so if we go into the parent material here,
and again, to get to it,
you can double click on the parent material below.
I already have my tab open.
Let's actually open this up to go full screen
and you can see what I have set up.
And we'll create a pretty simplistic one
where I can break down the theory here
when it comes to the subsurface
and a bit of the color information.
But I won't make it quite as complex as this
because I think you have the example
and you kind of get the idea of where things are going.
But I'm going to point out real quick what I have.
So I'm using the linear interpret node here,
and I'm using the A channel and the B channel.
And we're getting 50% of those values.
In here, we have a texture noise put into the alpha.
So we can actually blend things
and use that alpha to our advantage.
You'll see here, we have the amount of texture noise
and I'm pumping the green channel,
basically just some more black and white information.
And you can choose which channel has the most
or the strongest values in there.
And I'm putting it into the A channel of that multiply.
And then again, put it into another multiply
where the ERP, where the front of the ERP.
The ERP is a node we haven't developed yet.
So you'll see here, we have a ERP here on the other side
and this ERP is taking those color values
and making it so that if we wanted to,
we can even add more texture values
on top of what we've produced with the color.
It can, you can do it any way you want,
but I built it this way.
So you can get an idea of some of the cool stuff
that you can do to blend things together.
This isn't really necessary to be built for our class.
But again, I wanted to show you that in theory,
what you can do.
So down below here, this is where the things
get really important and being able to control
the look and feel of things.
You'll see I have a Fernal Index here.
And then in here, I have Opacity Surface Amount
as well as a Falloff Fernal Index.
Now this is the opacity.
This isn't the subsurface area, which is down below.
So if I wanted to, I could punch in a few things,
but remember this is controlling and mirroring
what could be happening with our object.
Now you're like wondering, well, Sean,
what is the mode of our object?
Well, if I click in the grid space,
you'll see that we have an opaque blend mode
as well as a subsurface for the shading model.
If I didn't have subsurface and move this back to default,
you'll see that the opacity goes away.
So the opacity is in here so that we can actually choose
when we choose our subsurface here on the top,
not profile, that's profile, it's different.
When we choose subsurface, it allows us to have
an opacity to be able to actually have light
kind of pass through it.
But what I mean by it bending and changing,
cause it isn't translucent,
is this Fernal Index pushes out a bit farther.
So we're able to have light go through it in such a way,
but it isn't quite translucent.
So it isn't like fully going through this.
We're controlling the amounts,
not necessarily how you can see through it,
but how the light imitates how it's passing
through an object.
So we're really not thinning it out.
We're actually just controlling how much of the intensity
of the light going through.
So it's a little bit of smoke and mirrors
when you think about it with Unreal.
Translucency will give you the true light passing through,
and you would control the roughness,
you control the opacity amount,
and then you can cloud it out or make it clear.
And this is not the case here.
We're actually controlling how much of the opacity
of the light coming through,
but we're not really making it translucent.
So hopefully that makes sense to you.
We're playing with those values.
And in here, the Fernal Index allows us to complement
that to be able to help with that illusion
and bend light a bit more in our scene
to be able to actually make it even look more extreme.
Now, if you go down below,
might press the wrong thing there.
We go down below to the subsurface.
We are using that Fernal Index to our advantage.
We're using an exponent here
and a base reflection refraction.
And each one of these have a different effect.
So the exponent, the edge subsurface Fernal Control
allows us to control how much of that edge
is being handled with the light.
And I'll show you what I mean.
Now, by default, I set it to 10.
Down below, you'll also see
there's a spec reflection thickness.
So let me show you what I mean.
So if we go down here and we go back
to our instance here,
you're gonna see the effect in real time.
So I'm gonna go to that subsurface area.
I'm going to increase this subsurface Fernal Control
so the edge here,
we can control how much this value is coming from the edge
of how that light is resting on that object.
Pretty cool.
Now the spec reflection thickness,
if I increase this,
you'll see that we're actually making it
so that it's kind of doled out.
But if we lower it,
we can actually make it so that we're getting,
it's almost like we're thickening the object.
So we're lessening the amount of light coming through.
But again, this is subsurface.
This isn't opacity,
but the Fernal Index is allowing us to fold the eye
and making you think
that we're controlling the thickness,
but we're really not.
We're really just using the Fernal Index to our advantage.
And that's the nice thing about plugging in a Fernal Index
into the subsurface node here.
It actually helps us push this look and feel.
Now, if I move my light around,
you'll actually see that effect a bit more
like I showed you earlier.
And you can see it kind of glow a bit here.
And again, we're fully in the eye
that Fernal Index is helping us not only in the opacity,
but it's also helping us when it comes to the subsurface.
All right, so let's go ahead
and build a simple one for ourselves here.
So you can get an idea
and I'll break things out a little bit more as we do so.
So let me go ahead and go into my Content Drawer.
And we're gonna go ahead and go to our class folder.
I'm gonna go to a demo folder.
And this is one we use off and on in this class series.
You can make your own demo folder if you wish.
And I'm gonna right click
and I'm gonna go into here
and just make it a brand new material.
This is going to be M underscore new subsurface SS demo.
There we go.
And I'm gonna double click on this.
He's off screen.
Let me go and pull this one over for a second here.
And let's actually open this up.
And we don't necessarily have to have a texture
in this one, but we might pick
on the ice materials textures
because they work really well.
So in here, let me go full screen
so you can see what I'm doing.
In here, we wanna make sure
that we're changing our shading model to a subsurface.
And again, when we do so, we have that opacity firing on.
Next, we wanna go in here and add a few things.
So we can keep things fairly simple
in the material department or texture department.
And we'll just choose a random blue, I guess you can do.
So I'm gonna keep my finger to three key left click
and we'll just make this a blue color.
Almost like a aqua blue and a navy blue mix.
And we can control that value and I'll hit okay.
I'm gonna pull that right into the color for now.
I'm gonna keep that pretty simple.
Not gonna worry about that too much.
Now, because it's subsurface,
it's pulling most of its color information from here
because it's imitating how light
is passing through an object.
So a lot of people get confused with that,
but that's kind of how that works.
And that's why it's white.
So don't let it mess with your noodle.
All right, so we have our base color.
And again, if I wanted to, I could build you intensity
and I can control the tint,
but you guys know that from other classes.
So I actually really don't need to waste time doing that.
What we can for fun though,
is promote some of these two variables,
such as metallic, promote to variable.
We'll do specular, move that over
and we'll promote roughness to variable, there we go.
And you can actually adjust those accordingly.
So if we wanted to,
we can mainly just stay in spec land
and set that to its default, which is 0.5.
Just a little tiny bit of shininess
and the rest we could set to zero or one,
depending what you need.
All right, so let's just move this over.
There we go.
I'm gonna move the color over here.
So now that we have that opacity to play with,
we can actually build kind of the same structure
that I had before for the jade.
So I'm gonna go in here and one,
I'm gonna create a couple of scalars.
So I keep my finger on the S key and left click
and this will be our first scalar.
And we'll call this opacity.
And I call it subsurface amount.
It's really not subsurface amount
when it comes to the opacity here.
This is more like opacity.
We could just say amount of light passing through
if it's helpful for you.
There we go.
That's kind of my intentions on that one.
So sorry if that was confusing.
And we're gonna say 0.95.
So the next thing we wanna do is create a Fernal index.
So let's go to that Fernal index.
Fresnel some people might say.
There we go.
Now you do have a Fresnel function.
We went over this in another class,
which it basically is a Fernal index
with a bit more control and stylization if you need it.
We just need to keep this simple one for now.
You're more than welcome to play with those if you want to.
In the end, if you plug those in
and adjust those accordingly,
it'll do the same thing that this one will do.
Just gives you a few more values.
All right, so the next one we need to do
is keep a finger of the S key.
I'm gonna create another, oops.
New control Z for a second.
There we go.
Keep a finger of the S key and left click.
That's what I wanted to do.
I'm gonna call this one our falloff Fernal effect.
So falloff effect.
There we go, falloff Fresnel effect.
And we'll set that to, I think my default is four.
There we go.
And we're gonna pull that string into that Fernal index.
We're gonna keep a finger of the M key
and make a multiply, pull that up.
And then we're gonna grab the one that we created here
and pull that into the A channel
and grab our Fernal index
and pull it into the B channel here.
And finally, we can keep a finger of the L key
and do a lerp.
So this lerp is now gonna have the B channel populated
by that multiply.
The original opacity control
cause you really do wanna control that
directly into the A channel.
But we wanna bring in that Fernal index
and we want it to compliment our environment.
So I did plug in my Fernal index into the B channel.
You don't really have to do that.
And my example doesn't have it.
So we can actually make it so that status for that
is just a one if you wanted to.
And we can bring this right into the alpha.
Now you can play with these values if you want to more
and you can play with different types of combos.
If we wanted to,
we could actually punch in another value in here
that would make, unfortunately it may compete
with what our intentions are for opacity.
Or if you wanted to, you could switch these up
and even have different types of nodes
that you wanna be able to play with
to be able to mess with this.
Like you could choose a material function if you wanted to.
And you can even make it pretty complicated.
There's even like a blur material function
that you wanted to play with.
You could just be careful with that one.
That's kind of expensive.
And we went over that in other classes.
But this is kind of what I have generally in our scene.
It actually works pretty well.
So I'm gonna grab this lerp here
and bring it into my opacity.
Cool.
Now again, we can choose how strong that's going to be.
But right now our color's pretty raw, right?
We don't have much of a color value in here.
So let's actually make a quick color value in here.
So I'm gonna go ahead and we'll begin
to wrap this up here.
I'm gonna go ahead and hit my finger on the S key.
This is going to be our edge subsurface color.
And we can say this is a Fresnel color.
Fresnel, Fresnel, Fresnel, for now people.
That's the Fresno pronunciation is called Fresnel.
And I'm gonna go ahead and keep my finger on the three key.
And this is gonna be our color.
And we're gonna actually try to imitate
what we had originally.
And let's go ahead and make that Fresnel index.
Here we go.
This Fresnel index is going to have
that edge subsurface in here.
We can do another S key.
And this will be our spec reflection thickness.
We can call this,
it's really not spec reflection thickness.
We can call it just overall thickness if we wanted to.
Spec and spec,
we can say imitated reflection thickness.
That's how you can think on that one.
And then we can go in here
and set that particular one to a 0.1 I think is my original.
Here we go.
And we can punch that into that base here.
And I forgot the number here needs to be on.
So we need to fire this on for thickness for the color.
And then finally we can grab the M key
and left click and we'll multiply.
And we can grab this here, color into the A channel
and pull this Fresnel index into the B channel.
And then from there we can go right
into our subsurface color.
Cool.
So we can get some really cool stuff on this one.
And let's go and apply it really quickly
to something simple.
So we're gonna go and just copy this guy.
So I'm gonna hit my alt key and move this one over.
And we're gonna find, I hit apply.
We're gonna find our material
and just drag it on this sphere.
Ooh, cool.
And we're getting some really cool effects on this.
And if you feel free, if you want to,
to move the light around and change the values
on an object to see what you get.
And you can actually get some really cool stuff.
And if you want it anytime, you can change the colors too.
So our original color was like blue.
If you want to, we can make it like kind of a pink
if we wanted to.
And you can get a combo of a really funky type
of look here where you got pink and we got blue
and you can make it look other worldly if you need to.
Well, that's it with this video.
In the next video, we're gonna go ahead
and take a look at ice up close
and different examples that we have for complexity
when it comes to subsurface materials.
Thanks again.